Suicide Squad was one of the most anticipated
movies of all time and when fans finally got
to see it, their opinions were very divided.
Some people were mad about the lack of The
Joker, others were thrilled with Margot Robbie’s
Harley Quinn and Will Smith’s Deadshot and
some people didn’t know what to think.
Regardless of where you stand, Suicide Squad’s
marketing made sure that people knew about
some of the crazy stuff that was happening
during it’s production.
We’ve compiled a list of some of the most
interesting tidbits in our list of 10 Suicide
Squad Behind The Scenes You Should Know About!
Enjoy the video and be sure to subscribe to
our channel for more great Screen Rant videos,
every day!
Harley and Joker Scenes
Suicide Squad was met with very divisive reviews
but one thing that pretty much everyone seemed
to agree on was that Margot Robbie was awesome
in the role of Harley Quinn.
Before the release of the film, Robbie actually
revealed she and Jared Leto did not rehearse
prior to filming their scenes and that all
of her reactions to his insanity were genuine.
This was a decision made by Robbie and director
David Ayer as they felt it would add a level
of danger and unpredictability to the Joker
and Harley relationship.
It seemed to have worked well as friends were
hungry for more Joker and of course, more
Harley.
Croc Story
Suicide Squad had a very big vast to deal
with and introduce and they did a pretty thorough
job of providing back-stories for all of the
main Squad members.
Unfortunately many of Killer Croc's backstory
scenes were removed from the final cut, including
scenes depicting his entire life as a social
outcast due to his physical appearance.
These scenes also would have shown Croc crossing
paths with Batman while he worked for various
crime bosses in Gotham.
One interesting scene would have even shown
Croc as a sculptor, but it didn’t make it
into the final cut.
The final film only gave us a small window
into Croc, which is too bad, because it seems
like he’s one interesting dude.
Joker Laugh
Most of the time, if you are lucky enough
to see a professional actor in the streets,
you want to go say hi and maybe even get a
photo.
This probably would not have been the case
if you had bumped into Jared Leto while he
was getting into character in the streets
of New York City and Toronto.
Leto reportedly was working on his Joker laugh
and was walking the streets testing out different
types of laughs, while studying which style
made people the most uncomfortable.
Joker Casting
These days fans follow the production of their
favorite movies from the moment they are announced
until they finally make it to the big screen.
Suicide Squad was no different as fans of
the series stayed informed on everything from
reshoots to casting rumors.
One thing that was kept rather quiet was that
Jared Leto wasn’t actually David Ayer’s
first choice to play the clown prince of Gothan.
In fact, Ryan Gosling was sought out first
for the role of The Joker.
It was reported that he turned down the role
because he didn’t want to sign on to a multi-movie
contract.
Jared Leto ended up in the role, and the rest
is history.
Body Hair
As one of the many bizarre things Jared Leto
did to prepare for his role as the Joker,
he also decided to shave his eyebrows in an
effort to make him look more deranged.
He wasn’t the only one who did this for
the movie, coincidentally, Jay Hernandez,
who played El Diablo, shaved his eyebrows
for his role since his character was designed
to have no hair on his body.
This choice saved Hernandez half an hour a
day in the makeup chair.
Unfortunately, Adewale Akinnuoye-Agbaje wasn’t
so lucky as it took the makeup team five hours
for the prosthetic make-up to be applied to
his head body each time he needed to shoot
a scene.
Harley Casting
While reading the comic books in preparation
to direct the film, David Ayer had Margot
Robbie in mind for the role of Harley Quinn.
This seemed like a good fit as she was just
coming off the major success of The Wolf Of
Wall Street and was beginning to shoot up
as a bankable broad.
However, Warner Bros offered Emma Roberts
the role first, but she turned it down to
star in Scream Queens.
Some other big actresses such as Alison Brie,
Rooney Mara, Olivia Wilde, Emma Watson, Zooey
Deschanel and many more were also considered
for the role of Harley Quinn.
Ultimately, Ayer got his way and Margot Robbie
became an amazing Harley Quinn.
Enchantress Prep
Cara Delevingne has had a very successful
modeling career and she has only lately starting
transitioning into more of an actor.
David Ayer is known for taking risks with
his movies and it he actually cast Cara Delevingne
before there was an actual script for Suicide
Squad.
It was reported that Ayer asked her to prepare
for her role as Enchantress by stripping naked
in the woods, preferably underneath a full
moon, and walking around in the dirt.
She obliged, in the privacy of her sister’s
country home and Ayer felt that she was right
for the role.
We aren’t sure if this is super creepy or
genius directing, we will let you decide.
SKWAD Tatoos
The marketing around Suicide Squad made sure
to let fans knows the crew of DC criminals
really were a solid squad, but it turns out
the actors took things one step further.
During the production of the film the majority
of the cast decided to get the word “SKWAD”
tattooed on them as a gesture of solidarity.
While most of them got it professionally done,
some people opted to let stars Margot Robbie
and Will Smith actually give them their tats.
While method acting is intense, it seems pretty
tame compared to permanently marking your
body for a role like the Suicide Squad did.
Footage Leak
Back in 2015, the first footage of Suicide
Squad was shown in a teaser trailer during
the Warner Bros. panel at San Diego Comic-Con.
The trailer was meant to be a glorified sizzle
reel, just showing off some of the best stuff
they had shot so far and Warner Bros. has
no intention of releasing this teaser to the
public.
Unfortunately, a low quality version was filmed
on someone’s phone and surfaced online.
This put Warner Bros in a very tough spot
and they felt obligated to release the footage
in HD and call it their first official trailer.
With how Suicide Squad turned out, maybe this
leak was the first indication that trouble
was a brewing.
Leto On Set
By this point it is pretty common knowledge
that Jared Leto got up to some crazy stuff
while getting in character for his role as
The Joker.
Anyone who was on set with Leto was happy
to tell the press how uncomfortable he made
everyone feel and how he refused to break
character between scenes.
Will Smith has even stated that he feels like
he has never truly met the real Jared Leto.
Leto also famously sent his cast-mates some
pretty unorthodox gifts such as a dead hog,
used condoms, creepy poems and a ton more.
This all seems like a lot of work to get into
character, but Leto is an academy award winner
so we will have to trust him!
So there’s our list of ten behind the scenes
Suicide Squad facts that you need to know!
What did you think of the movie?
Are you excited to see a Suicide Squad sequel?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more fun videos – like this one!